Speaker 1: Absolute chaos took place in Kansas
over a Republican elected official who was
apparently moonlighting as a substitute teacher
and is accused of kicking a student, as we
used to say, in the balls or in the balls,
as you know, who he used to say among all
sorts of other wild and wacky things.
I'm talking about Kansas State Representative
Mark Samuel.
Yes, he's a Republican.
He filled in at Wellsville High School in
Wellsville, Kansas, last Wednesday.
Sam Zell represents this very area in the
state legislature that includes Wellsville
and the school.
Sam Zell apparently went bonkers trying to
push what is a kind of pseudo religious agenda
on the children.
He was berating some of the teenagers.
He was pleading with them to follow God.
He was asking them about their masturbation
habits, was demanding that the children make
babies because it, quote, feels good, and
claiming that a sophomore at the school must
be contemplating suicide because they have
lesbian parents.
And then as if that's not enough, things really
got nuts for lack of a better term.
When Samso allegedly grabbed one student,
pushed him against the wall, attacked another
by invoking the, quote, wrath of God, hitting
him intentionally in the testicles and then
inviting others in the class to do the same.
Here is some of the rant which was caught
on video and audio
Speaker 7: made babies realize making babies
doesn't procreate.
If you have an activity, don't answer that.
Thank you.
I told you not to.
God does.
God already knows you're afraid and angry.
I think the wrath of God.
Do you believe me when I tell you that God
has been speaking to me?
I could put the wrath of God on you right
now because that's what you should run and
scream.
Get out of my room and you're going to hurt
worse than childbirth, which is because you
have permission to kick him.
So who put together the Bible?
Multiple stories from different people.
It was we were just wondering why it was multiple
different editors tried to one of the stories
while there were distractions from the Bible.
Come on.
Proof is on the way get.
Simply no different, but I don't play.
I think no matter how much differently,
Speaker 1: you know, I had some pretty wacky
substitute teachers in elementary school and
middle school in high school, never anything
remotely close to this, that's for sure.
He has since admitted that he planned his
actions, but says he did nothing wrong.
I don't know what that means.
The 36 year old Republican was arrested on
charges of alleged misdemeanor battery.
Already, a lot of people who saw the video
saying there has to be a felony in there.
How is this only misdemeanors?
He was booked into the Franklin County Adult
Detention Center.
He's been released on a thousand dollars bond.
Now, in case you were wondering, the superintendent,
Ryan Bradbury, said Samuel will no longer
be a substitute teaching in the school district.
I'm curious how the Kansas Republican Party
will respond to this.
They've I've not heard anything from them
at this point.
Some people wrote to me and said, you know,
David, this is not really about politics or
religion.
This is a psychotic break.
This is merely a mental health incident.
He just sort of happens to be obsessed with
things like accepting God.
But there's really nothing political here.
I agree that this is not a stable and well-balanced
person.
There's no question about it.
Beyond that, there's there remain questions.
And in a later Snapchat post, Samso reportedly
claimed that, quote, Every little bit of it
was planned to send a message about art, mental
health, teenage suicide, how we treat our
educators and one another to parents and grandparents
of Wellsville.
So I guess going to I the kids and I, we did
this together to send some kind of a message,
a very strange way to send the message for
sure.
And we will follow the court proceedings and
see what ultimately takes place.